una llama extraordinaria arde en la
central rusa de gas natural licuado de
puerto vaya según un análisis de rist at
energy compartido por la bbc- rusia
estaría quemando en esta planta 4 34
millones de metros cúbicos de gas
natural diarios un volumen que moscú
podría vender por 10 millones de dólares
al día además la combustión libera 9 mil
toneladas de co2 diarias en latitudes
árticas una región en deshielo donde la
temperatura global aumenta cuatro veces
más rápido que en el resto del planeta
la propia compañía rescate energy
declaró a la bbc- que se desconoce el
motivo de esta intensa actividad de
combustión en puerto vaya desconocemos
las razones exactas de la quema pero el
volumen las emisiones y la localización
de la llama son un recordatorio visible
de la posición de dominio de rusia en
los mercados energéticos europeos
la planta está ubicada cerca del inicio
del nord stream 1 el gaseoducto que
conecta a rusia con alemania funciona el
20 por ciento de su capacidad según
moscú por cuestiones técnicas según
bruselas pues represalias a las
sanciones europeas en todo caso la falta
de mercado donde exportar el gas es una
de las explicaciones que los expertos
dan a esta liberación masiva de
hidrocarburos rusos mientras rusia quema
excedente la unión europea se afronta la
escasez todos podemos constatar que la
abundancia de gas que hemos conocido es
complicada hoy en día está comprometida
por el conflicto en ucrania y nosotros
apoyamos a nuestros vecinos y nuestros
hermanos ucranianos pero esto tiene
consecuencias incluido para los
franceses en el acceso al gas los
precios de la energía ya están superando
récords a lo ancho del continente como
respuesta política a la dependencia
energética de rusia la unión europea
impulsó un plan de reducción del 15 por
ciento del consumo eléctrico hasta marzo
de 2023 una directiva que países como
españa y alemania ya han empezado a
aplicar